欢迎收看最佛心幽默的财经节目
理财达人秀
我是李兆华
好 回答这一次真的不一样啰
昨天缴出来的财报展望
真的让市场非常的惊讶
因为明年预估还要再成长70%
这件事情有机力回答在盘后
大涨4到5个百分点
也让今天台股一开的时候
是先往上冲
一度有涨到500点左右
不过呢
尾盘的气势有点压下来
中场上涨了142点
好 大家难免会猜想
到底是不是这个
灰达财报的激励
又是这么昙花一现呢
但说实话
今天盘面上
创高的公司还是相当多
尤其是今天反弹上来
已经又几乎逼近反弹高了
有没有机会过反弹高
再往下一关
就是历史新高迈进呢
可能量能还要稍微再补一下
不过因为众多的领头羊
我们等一下一一帮您数
会排列出栏
您可以去选这些强势的
以及到底还有哪一些这波反弹
好像还没有轮到它
事实上好戏在9月的
我们今天都会一一点名给您听
首先欢迎第一位来宾
古科大夫 龙医生Eason
Eason要来好好的讲
这一次回答的财报
为什么会让华尔街
非常惊艳一改前面
实际盘后下跌的历史
但是能不能延续
他觉得有一些方向
要帮我们做研究了
但是围绕在辉达的供应链
今天盘面上大力光继续创高
联雅创历史新高
CPO这个族群真的不能忽视
还有辉达在力捧的机器人
今天蒙力也创高
再来老AI你觉得
好像没有太大的表现
可是他们是最具价值的
所以围绕在辉达
今天提供您三大产业
细细来跟您说分明
第二位是我們的行男股神魏亮哥
魏亮哥說如果今天都已經快要創下反彈高了
那離新高真的不遠了
只是往新高的路上我們要留意
每一次領軍的族群都不同
今天會來告訴你
例如載板 例如散樂 例如銅箔
到底這些領軍的我們該怎麼挑
今天很厲害的
同族群中教您做對價的交易
還有今天立法院通過了2400億的無人機條款可是我們看到雷虎是鎖掌停後打開不過我兩個說接下來軍工很可能會拉出一波的漲勢等一下慢慢跟您講了好第三位是我們的黃金右下角選股教練薇泰
好不要忘記喔
匯達財報在8月底開出來大家很開心
但是9月有大事情更值得留意
蘋果的新機發表
我們的半導體展都非常厲害
尤其蘋果這一次應該會有折疊機
還有一顆超厲害的新晶片
把台积电的2nm包产能辣包起来
所以到底平盖股
如果它是一个多期的身份
加上现在还没有谈很多的
设备股跟特化股
黄金右下角
等一下来慢慢跟您说
首先有请谷克代夫
您说这一次
不会探得太深过来
不但没有探得很深
现在还几乎要创下反弹高了
就是因为挥打
这次的表现依旧是
让华尔街觉得非常厉害
但是今天压尾盘
有沒有什麼事情怪怪的
要幫我們講
再來圍繞再揮打CPU老AI機器人
該怎麼選
好 今天這個揮打財報
早上開出來的時候
大家本來心就量了一半
為什麼
一開出來是跌的
好 後來到底發生什麼事情
叫依循傳統
我們先看它在指數部分
那在月線這邊支撐
我們跟大家講說
這個不會下來打這麼深
那所以四萬四到四萬六這個位階
外資是連續在做個買進
而融資是縮手的
那我們看到在價錢元指數
其實最開始發動就是
從前天的低點
大家如果他影響前天那天本來是盤中
低了大概500多點
那後來盤中是拉起來收紅
結果昨天又再一根
所以事實上從前天低點
到今天最高點已經2000點了
就是這個差距實上已經蠻大的
所以今天當然有一些短線資金
看起來就是在做一個落跑
那美元指數的話呢
這邊跟大家講說台幣轉升
那台幣轉升當然主要的因素
我覺得這一次貝森特也幫了不少忙
瘋狂的去買債
讓美元指數壓下來
所以我們看到資金也轉進在
風險資產比特幣的部分
最近從5萬多直接飆到8萬多
這個都表示市場的風險偏好在做改變
到底指數可不可以再過歷史新高呢
我覺得注意今天晚上的美股
那不可以漲幅回吐太多
有點擔心
對因為回答他這個今天
盤後看起來股價是漲了5%那就是今天晚上美股開盤之後呢那不可以像台股這樣留一個比較大的這個賣壓上影線那再來就是呢明天之後最好可以持續維持在一兆以上這樣子一個成交量
噪元量
對因為今天盤中的這個成交量預估啊
本來還是有大概快要一兆左右
可是隨著盤中高檔震盪越來越縮
越來越縮
那到後來就只剩下大概9000多億了
那所以全子股呢
也要進入到一個表態
包括外資的空單呢
那持續的
不可以再做一個往上的增加
因為現在外資比較多是在呈現這樣
套利的一個動作
那所以維持一個
大概84.4到85.5的空檔
我覺得還是可以接受的
那重要就是美元
如果再持續的走路的話
台幣升值是有利於外資
再持續的做一個回補
好 所以今天感覺上雖然不錯
但是壓尾盤和量能沒有出來
有點美中不足
是 好那我們看輝達
早上的這個財報
那一開始公布出來
大家對於它的一個毛利率
仍然是雞蛋你挑骨头
是
那毛利率公布出来
比预期的大概还要少了
1到1个1.5个百分点
所以一开始开出来的时候
它是下跌的
可是后来他讲了两件事情
就下一个季度
就是明年一整年的营收
还要再成长70%
这非常强劲
全球前三大市值的公司
那个营收还可以再增加70%
好猛 比台积电开得还猛
对 真的非常强
那再来就是
但是他說亞馬遜對於灰達晶片
還會再持續擴大採購
所以這個又讓市場吃下一個定心丸
那包括財報的亮點
營收年增資料中期也是年增
那下一季營收預估
已經快要破1100億了
重點是Rubin的營收
開始去做一個貢獻
在這一季就開始了
所以相關的台廠供應鏈
其實今天看起來
老回來的部分有一些表現
那當然就是受惠
這個毛利率的部分
其實也推了HBM一把
因為就是在記憶體太貴了
所以今天早上
那財報一開出來之後
記憶體也跟著拉起來
包括美光
在韓國的這個部分
那另外呢
CPU電源散熱這些等等
都是在接下來的一個
技術架構的一個重心
所以呢
在2027年看起來
基礎建設仍然是持續的擴張
甚至延續到2028年
所以我們看到會達財報呢
我覺得今天我給他90分了
但是90分歸90分
因為市場怎麼去看待
跟短線資金怎麼去做一個
判別我覺得還是要去注意一下
是 你是給90分是你的標準蠻嚴格的耶對 因為毛利率等等還是有一一些要講話還是可以講但我覺得真的已經非常棒了盤頭已經漲勢
重點是今天晚上不可以
這個比如說收斂
變兩趴 甚至還到平盤
那就可能後面整理的
這個時間可能會再拉長
好 當然他也有提到
這個毛利率到明年底
可能會降到71到72
但真的已經算非常厲害
重點在繼續撒錢
它的營收成長
就會再給台灣台廠供應鏈訂單
所以你會用什麼樣的順序
來幫大家介紹
最強的應該是CPU
對 我們看到這一波
最為強勢當然就是在CPU的部分
因為包括未來
即將要進入這樣高速傳輸的世代
所以從本來的算力
成為這樣子一個運算的
傳輸的這樣子一個速率
更為重心
因為銅線它就是有這樣一個
傳輸的極限
那目前如果採用這樣CPU架構
就是在Scale Art的部分
每1.67的這樣傳輸效率
可以把功耗大幅度的降低
甚至快要來到70%的這個幅度
那這個對於在需要高速傳輸的
這個在機櫃之內
不管是GPU對GPU的連線
或者是跟光纖交換器
當中的一個連線
那我覺得目前
都是往這個方向去做個發展
所以我們看台廠部分
封裝像台積電
訊星還有日月光
同樣在CPU的封裝當中
會有相關的利多
以及在光模組的部分
大力光是這一波比較入列的新兵
好猛快7000了
對 包括其實它最近又有
蘋果相關的題材
所以幾乎說是雙漆的題材
那在上全Poloway等等
又有相關的
跟這個輝達跟彈吉田做一個合作
另外零化音的缺貨
像全新聯亞 IET 這些等等
是這一波CPU最新
最開始做一個表態的
好 今天也是光學類刷一排障聽
那主要我認為應該就是
大力光所帶動的
那包括像連一光
還有玉金光
然後剩下這個陽明光
今天表現非常強
都創高了耶
對 那當然
其中有一些是CPO的
那有一些是光學族群
被大力光帶起來
我覺得指標然是要看
大力光的部分
那現在這個
看起來投信一直連買
那股價已經創歷史新高了
那包括接下來
蘋果準備要拉貨了
這個在它的這個題材當中
其實我覺得最重要是在
蘋果後續的一個動能
那另外在
沒有講到是蘋果的動能
現在是很有趣的一個現象
對 那另外在這個
老的CPU
像潛頂 上泉這一排
那他們都有各自的
本來的一個利基
包括也有在新高的像聯亞
聯亞今天創歷史新高真的好猛喔
全新也是快到新高
全新也快到新高了
那我覺得這個都是暗示
第一季實際上CPU都漲過一大波
那很多CPU可能還是
就是他們都有這種腰骨的體質
那現在其實隨著到2027年
要進入量產元年了
我覺得大家反而可以去注意
第一季其實有飆過一段的CPU
現在可能還在半山
或是還在偏低檔的位階
其實我覺得第四季到第一季
馬上做夢的行情又來了
時間過得很快
所以在這個CPU題材當中
我覺得從第一季走過一次
然後第二季修正下來
修正到第三季
他們都是屬於先跌先止跌的
在七月當中
那很多的股票
可能都還在相對偏低檔的位置
好 被伊森講得有點感傷
第一季漲的
現在可能第四季接第一季
又是做貿行情
我們一年要過完啦
對馬上又快過年
雖然說還有五個月了
是
那大力光呢也這個
非常強勢也漲成快要變腰骨了
這幾乎快連續三根漲
6915快要七字頭的大力光
對不會因為這個乖利真的很大
這個只要稍微籌碼
有一些鬆動可能就會
你看漲了這麼多啊
漲這麼多隨便回一個
假設10% 15%的話
那也要回一個
可能快要一段距離了
所以要注意這個追高的風險
那聯亞的話就是
環步再做一個墊高
那這個漲停板的位置
之前有跟大家說
因為這邊是低檔
主力去把成本把它拉開了
連續五根的跳高
跳高往上做一個拉開成本
所以這個地方不太會
再被做一個測試了
所以實際上聯亞有稍微
拉回到十日線
或者在比較低的位階
就可以去注意一下
好 國科在8月6號跟大家講
雖然已經連續跳空了
可是放量了
資金有進來
不會短短一週就全部出掉
只要有壓回
就可以去留意整體CPO族群
對 那CPO其實都是這樣
越來越多的資金進來的話
那其實就會帶動一些中小型的股票
像1908潛頂
也是穩住月線之後
開始做一個突破
今天突然表態
因為資金比較弱
對 那這種就是我剛講的
開始有這種比較落後的
有補漲的一個力道
包括它的一個融資
還是維持在一個低檔那雖然說昨天融資有大增但是看這樣子一個買法比較不像一般散戶的融資會這樣突然大買的比較像是橫角色的融資橫角色是不是
那包括AI推動高速的光模組
400G跟800G的部分
它都已經完成驗證
並且開始量產
明年的話1.6G放量
那另外它的這個外置的雷射光源
因為雷射在使用光中
當中會有這種過熱的問題
那它的一個解法就是把雷射光源
移到旁邊一點點
讓它這個光源可以去做
不要太過熱
那瞄準的AI Server
還有在CPU Switch的一個部分
另外它的CW Laser的新產線也完成了
包括它傳統在本業的部分
也開始復甦了
所以位階相對偏低
那如果資金再開始進來
量能如果都有持續在放量出來的話
表示開始有資金進去做卡位
是 看到這種低位階
大家可能會比較幹啦
是 對
那另外則是在這個聯誼光
就是比較高位階
好 那聯誼光的話
它大戶持股增加而且主力轉買
那像這樣比較強勢呢
都不拉回的話
可能稍微等到實現
就可以開始去做第一批的卡位
那它法術也表示
CPU的這個產品都會開始使用光學玻璃
所以包括像是在毛胚
以及在材料部分已經切入
有相關的一個營收
另外歐洲的這個大廠的訂單
也開始續徵
包括醫療檢測
休閒望遠鏡
還有在瞄準鏡這些等等
所以營收跟毛利率都有
同步做一個改善
那開始有這樣多方排列呢
事實上第一次拉回都可以再去做一個
偏多的看待
聯繫光其實獲利沒有很好
可是它是他們鏡頭的上游
對不對 光學玻璃跟材料
所以看起來很值得期待
跟大力光有結盟嗎
對 那我覺得這一波就是光學
主要還是看大力光
都很多被帶起來的
這樣子一個小兵
那另外呢則是在
老AI的部分
跟機器人的部分呢
我覺得在回答財報過後
大家可以持續留意這個題材
包括最近這一個月呢
那其實都有在做一個持續買進的
這樣的一個狀況
好 所以我們先來看
老A的廣達
好 廣達呢
因為之前有發這個GDR
對啊 那先吃一根跌停啊
對 那我記得GDR換算回來
台幣大概是兩百八十幾塊
那現在又回到這個價位之上
所以我覺得這個GDR
轉換過來的這個價錢
應該可以當作是它實質的一個支撐
是
那它的這個大戶持股
相對比較穩定
外資最近期也開始在做一個轉買
像一次你剛好來他最慘的那一天那你有提到一個重點你說這個跳空缺口要把它補起來現在補好了嗎補啦這個已經已經完全補了那只是稍微再回測一下就不用太擔心了對不對
對
好
跟台股一樣
我覺得也不會打第二隻腳
也不會打
也不會打這麼深了
對我覺得這個價位
其實就已經是蠻便宜的
好 蠻甜的了
對
對 已經把這個利空因素
消化掉了
可以大家放心
對 老A總會有反應的一天
是
好 另外我們看在2464的盟利
我們一直都相當看好的機器人
今天再創立時興高
因為在機器人過去一段時間
主要大家看著在自動化機器人掌
還有機器人運動會
那在接下來馬上9月份是在台積電的
台灣的半導體展要登場
那它其實也是台積電COVAS
相關的一個自動化的一個夥伴
已經切入COPOS新世代的
先進的一個封裝供應鏈
那相關的這個訂單
已經開始做一個交貨
再手訂單突破100億元
那包括呢
他的跟這個閩石集團
全球汽車供應鏈
還有盟利機器人
都有這樣自動化的一個合作
那我們看到大戶持股相對來的穩定
以及呢
主力開始有在做一個轉買的動作
那今天算是突破
這麼長的一個區間的一個漲停板
那如果後面有
還有行情的話
大家可以去注意一下
今天的開盤架的這個位置
有沒有守住
因為今天市場沒有開得很高
那今天等於說在開一個小高之後
是往上拉速漲停
它是在今天機器人族群當中
它跟值得是唯一有漲停的
所以後續如果可以穩住在
今天開盤價之上的話
應該還有這個波段行情
可以去注意一下
好 其實蠻值得關注的
因為上個18月20號來講
剛好也是一個相對比較低
還沒碰到月線它就上去
可是你有提醒
因為它的法人籌碼是蠻集中的
那時候我有問一個問題
會不會展覽結束了
題材就沒了
結果你說會有延續性
那這個就是一個
證明有延續性的漲停板
是因為工具區這個族群
我覺得最慘的狀況已經過去了
就在去年關稅那個時間點
那包括其實這一次的
這個301勞動調查的條款
台灣的稅率是低於日韓的
所以在包括日幣也走深
那這個都有預理台廠
去競爭這些美國的訂單
是 所以現在整個盤面氣氛
看起來真的是往好的方向
這邊非常謝謝Eason
好還記得Eason
上個禮拜四來有提到
台股就算在回測
也回測不了多深
今天一口氣彈上來
幾乎要創下反彈高
不過晚上觀察一下回答喔
今天盤後的這個5%氣勢要做延續免得市場又在響東響西但是如果訂單都來台灣的話不妨看一下CPO 聯亞大力光真的太強了
幫您挑出正在敘詩待發的CPO
以及機器人
真的好厲害喔
之前講不是只有看展題材
接下來它會走出一個波段
今天猛烈的漲停就有這樣的味道
法人的籌碼依舊集中在這個族群
值得您繼續做追蹤留意囉
好 廣告回來
我們型男股神
我兩個要上場了也要來聊喔
假如我們有機會再去挑戰
48000點的欠高的話
其實主流族群現在已經集結了
不管是載版同伯基版
甚至今天通過預算的軍工股
到底該怎麼挑
等一下提南股神教您挑
我是股市分析師
同時也是兩個孩子的爸爸
很多人常問我
到底該幫小孩存台積電
還是0050
其實我的答案很簡單
其實只要定期定額
以年化報酬率8%估算
互利累積下來
孩子成年18歲都會有第一桶金
而問我最看重的是哪一檔股票
在我心中
當然就是我的孩子
孩子的黃金發育期只有一次
所以更應該幫孩子存未來
在孩子轉大人的關鍵期
我的秘密武器就是這個
莊廣核糖轉大人翠滴金
由台灣第一位女中醫師
莊淑琦博士開例
有曾外孫三胞胎成長實證
男女配方不同的
成龍成鳳配方
剛好可以精準補給黃金晴營養
是不是都沒有苦味和腥味
做下去跟媽媽煮的雞湯
也好喝的
嗯 還好喝
投資 我會挑龍頭股
陪孩子成長
我挑有實證的龍頭品牌
這才是最精準的健康投資
好 雖然指數沒有創高
但我們有發現
有蠻多族群都有代表股創高了
例如今天星星 景碩 宰版
我們一直都幫大家追蹤的
可是大家難免要問
創高不敢追
沒有問題
今天為了要教我們一個配對交易
這個太猛了
剛才我先偷看你的圖
所以你要發現
現在其實有一些主流已經先表態了
還沒等大盤
我們先告訴大家
我是最強的
載板很強
銅箔今天也有表態
軍工到底該怎麼看
今天雷虎沒有所掌停
還殺尾盤
我想其實回答的Valubin量產
讓很多AI科技股
我真的吃了定心丸
那這一波當然指數慢慢
已經來到46000
逼近前高48000
其實基本上指數
只要大概在推升
不到5個百分點
就能夠創新高
应该是先买创高的股票
还是去找一些
目前可能还在底部制服的股票
我个人觉得
其实从7月份的
所谓的小股灾发生以来
这一波指数已经算是V转了
确实因为有很多领头羊
包括像铜箔基板
光通讯散热
这里面大家看
这个是分类股的指数
这基本上几乎都快要创新高
那更不要说像铜箔基板
台光电台要联傲
前後連續都有創新高
散熱裡面又有齊紅建設
光通訊 聯亞
還有像大力光
雖然還沒有被納入指數
不過也有包括光環等等
其實都大漲
我覺得就是有點像打仗的時候
打仗的時候
如果我們都快要攻下攤頭堡
怎麼樣
那你前面衝過去的
第一批的將士
你能夠往後退嗎
絕對不能
你一路只能攻過去了
這個氣勢才會強
所以我認為
在大盘准备要去供
4万8的过程
这些创高的股仍然是首选
第二个原因
因为现在的成交量
虽然有稍微温和放大了
两到三天
但是还没有看到
单日回到一兆元以上
还没 今天本来以为有
对 如果现在成交量
已经回到1.2兆
1.3兆 1.5兆
那当然就会扩散
到更多可能低位阶的股票
也会开始反攻
所以我认为现阶段
如果你资金有限
操作节奏上
还是先抓
这些比较强势的领头族群
然后持续的去观察
落后股里面
有没有便宜又大碗的标的
这是第二次挑战反弹4万6000
已经发现有人是两波都强
有人是本波没跟上
你建议看两波都强的
对 那就代表说是市场的聪明资金
包括大户跟法人先锁定的
那这也表示说
其实这一轮的急煞
在跟V转出现之后
真的有点财富重分配
因为如果你看指数好像
已经几乎快要回来了
没事情了
死报原来的标的
有的套牢说穿了
到目前为止
一个月了还是套牢
那刚刚提到的
像这个铜箔基板
或者是说像窄板
都是目前盘氏当中
特别有高能见度
法人资金非常认同的族群
那我们常说
像窄板有四雄
但我更喜欢讲的是三加一雄
为什么呢
因为大家可以看一下
南电新兴跟景硕
其实他们的ABF跟BT的比较
相對都是很高的 純度很高那當然針領在全世界的PCB它的產值是第一大的近年來也積極擴廠然後投入到載板的發展
不過事實上如果以現階段
它的BT跟ABF加總起來
其實大概只有一成左右
相對來說
這個時候我覺得磐絲
因為剛才講嘛
資金量還沒有那麼大
那市場的氛圍也還沒有到說
真的一片樂觀
所以這個時候
它的評價就會有點尷尬
到底是要適用載板的高本益比
還是回到以前PCB
比較低的本益比
那我們會發現
這一波其實南電跟星星
先後都曾經來到了
就是四位數 千元
可是我發現
這兩張股票
當然你買誰
我覺得都不會有錯
可是如果要增加一點操作樂趣
樂趣嗎
或者是貪心
想要再多賺一點價差的話
我常講 錢有限
那怎麼做呢
配對交易
什麼意思
因為南電未來的EPS
會顯著高於新興
而且會拉開
我們可以讓大家再看一次
你會發現到
2027 2028 持續漲價
對耶
明年開始就會開始拉開來
然後如果真的能見度
延伸到2028年
南電可能是要來到110塊
新興是66塊錢
就拉開來
差那麼多
順帶一提
景碩基本上
明年EPS還輸給新興
可是到2028年之後
可能會比肩甚至有點微幅要超車
這是來自於外資高盛證券的預測
對 所以回到這個EPS的角度之後
我們再來看股價就知道說
因此當南電如果落後星星的時候
像今年五月份的時候
我認為這就是嚴重不合理
那這個時候你不用死爆星星
我反而會把星星賣一趟或減碼
把部分資金挪去操作南電
你看這一段南電的股價就很強
創下歷史新高
好 結果它一下子衝過頭之後
不但領先星星
拉開了高達400多塊錢的時候
因為這段時間
星星確實就很弱
還真的相反
通常在我自己觀察
大概如果差距到了400塊的時候
那這個時候反而我又會
從南電的資金撤出來
轉戰星星
那你看這一波上來
星星是先創高了
不過昨天這兩者
幾乎又是平起平坐
一個1200 一個1180
沒差距怎麼辦
結果今天南電
好像聽到了我的召喚今天就噴上漲停不過景碩喊缺貨這個也不意外但我形容說他好像也順便幫很多同業開了法說會因為有一個重點他提到其實他現在營收
還沒有真正來到他的天花板
還應該有更強的成長
可是相對受到缺料的影響
缺什麼呢
像TGAS 薄鮮布
所以他開完法說會之後
南亞很強
包括其實像昨天
富橋也蠻強的
當然景碩今天也是創新高
那这个大家其实就是观察一下
只要投信
持股还在加码的话
我觉得呢
沿着五日均线往上去做
移动停地是没有问题的
但是一般来说
如果碰到四位数
就是一千大宽的时候
可能会稍微震荡一下
好 但是刚才提到
既然往上游来讲缺料
对
会不会下一个呢
也准备要来挑战四位数的
是京居呢
好 因为上游材料
虽然富桥最近复苏了
可是前阵子其实都没它的细
京居也是
股災的时候跌得超级惨
所以会不会回到
封在材料的身上
好 那因为呢
这个千金
我是不敢打包票
如果有问题
请找高盛证券
现在才500不到
高盛的目标价940
大家看看就好
我觉得重点是什么
其实不管是高盛的预估
或其他外资
还有本土反而预估
我觉得成长的方向非常一致
今年我们都知道
经居其实获利没有很好
对
所以你如果从今年的角度
都会觉得本益比好高
可是2027到2028
那我觉得姑且也不要先去管2029
对 我刚才正想问你说
2029能信吗
那我觉得现在看2027
是最有把握的
以现在它的股价来说
其实你就发现
本益比还在一字头
它真正的业绩爆发的主升段
本来就是落在
从大概今年的第三季开始启动
那到明年
所以上半年的业绩不好
或是说今年一整年EPS
好像沒有很特別高
我覺得都算是正常的
那比較特別的是
股價當然前面的時間
大家辛苦了
跌得跌很深
但是因為賣方看起來
也有點息壽
所以你有沒有發現
它這一段下跌的過程當中
其實沒有太大的量
我可以感受到息壽
因為很多股民就會覺得
這麼有競爭力的銅箔
是高階的 有寡占地位的
為什麼會跌成這樣
可是今天這樣
你說不心痛是不可能的
那既然如果沒有融資
那我就呢 吸收 續爆 忍耐一下
忍耐
那我們發現呢
忍到什麼時候呢
忍到就是現在
為什麼呢通常我量最喜歡看的是均量線大家看這兩條線紅色跟藍色五日跟十日均量线那我先用五日均量线来画这个地方你看它当时的均量在这个位置
现在的均量在这个位置
多很多了
左边下跌这个过程都没什么量
右边落底反攻打底的过程
你看最近的量都蛮大的
所以我觉得代表现在大户开始
又重新吸纳筹码了
逢低去做回补跟加码
那很好玩的是
外资其实都站在卖方
甚至投信也站在卖方
可是他们卖了这么多连续卖
股价从270涨到500块钱
谁 是谁
那就表示有聪明钱
又是聪明钱
把筹码收走了
因为业绩好的公司
7月营收创新高
如果8月再开出
漂亮的成绩的话
我觉得法人
大概率就会回补
再加上这一条
重要的中期多空线
也就是季线
今天收盘站上去了
我知道很多资金
其实他往往会看什么
就是你的中期趨勢
有沒有扭轉
站上季線之後
包括一些城市交易
都可能會做回補
好 這個就看法人跟不跟
對不對 對
好 那財務朋友
他如果這一波下到了
到什麼時候
會是比較好的停歷時機
我覺得大家其實
接下來你就看
只要它開始爆量之後
流上影線或黑K
就像你看它前面
這個地方都會開始
流上影線跟黑K
那這種狀況之下就代表
我們講這一段聰明前
開始繞跑了
或者如果真的後續發生
外資買 投信買
顛倒過來想
怎麼股價漲不動了
那也是聰明其實在落跑
二流的看外資投信
但一流的你要看
跟外資投信對做的
好 還要很特別的觀察
好 這個是在銅箔的部分
那今天有一個最新的新聞
就是無人機的條例
通過的版本是2400億
聽說是一個mix的版本
沒錯
不過這個軍工股很奇妙
都會先知道或先壓寶
但尾盤殺下來
是觉得这个条例不够吸引人吗
到底该怎么判断
这个悬而不绝
我觉得是对产业是最大的伤害
那一旦确定了
我觉得朝野一致的方向
虽然细节内容不同
可是大家都知道
台湾要发展无人机很重要
而且我们还要吃到国外的政策
那之前美国的关税政策
其实摆明就是去红化
所以也有利于台湾的订单涌入
因此在投资国防军工股当中
很简单
我认为就是八字绝
內外要通吃
海陸要雙親
海就是無人見 無人挺
那陸則是在
這個無人機的部分
那其實我們來看一下
這一次呢
最重要的指標股漢翔
它其實已經接近創高了
那它市值最大
所以漢翔能夠高姿態
那就代表呢
大資金沒有跑
它認同會往上
那再來今天一早
很快就升空起飛的
是雷虎
它的股性向來就是最活潑
所以雷虎會長呢
也代表呢
靈活的資金也知道呢
這個有細唱
後面有行情
所以呢
因为国内的军工国防股
相对来讲他们股本都很小
那这个2400亿的商机
我觉得应该初期来讲
语入均沾
没有哪一家公司
有足够大的产量跟股本
把这个商机说我几乎要通包了
所以应该都会语入均沾
那尤其股本小的公司
你就要留意一下
筹码的集中度如何
那这边我会先建议就是
一个去看一下
这个反制无人机系统的创宏科技
因为虽然我们都很说
剛剛講的漢翔 雷虎 長榮 韓海
可是你今天選的
可能是投資朋友比較不清楚
在軍工裡面有符合你講到的
內外要通吃 海路要雙漆這件事
對 那因為它本身就是代理了
這個反制無人機的系統
那大家應該有去看過
美國有叫納斯達克公司
OMDS 對
那它已經收購了以色列這家公司
所以等於現在這個產品
就是由創紅來說一個代理
好 認識一下
當然它相對來說
成交量是比較小
所以切記呢
操作這種股票
千萬不要是以追高的模式
你要拉回在它的上升趋势线附近
去留意是不是浮现了转强的机会
但它筹码看起来
有一点点像隔日冲在琢磨
要不要担心呢
这简单来说
因为相对就刚刚你有提到
比较大家不熟悉
所以过去它焦头比较清淡
所以有时候会有一些资金
专门在做量
是 做量
进出 进出
这个就是做量
它量就是慢慢有一点
你看增温出来了
但是确实你要留意
因为上一波这个地方
它的量真的比现在大蛮多的
所以这个就要看
是不是像汉翔 雷虎
真的能够把整个产业的那种
攻击的气势带出来
如果有更多资金进来
我觉得这个地方
它就有机会去做突破
好 反制无人机
对 另外军工产业
还有一个新小旗
新的题材 小的个股
然后旗兵
我好久没听到这三个字了
新小旗 对
多么棒的领悟
发现原来栗珊已經從工具機再跨到健身器材再跨到無人機的動力系統大家可以到官網去查查看這是官網下載的圖片它其實主攻就是無人機的馬達跟動力系統
目前已經其實接到非常非常多的訂單
所以看起來有第一波先知者已經進場
拉回整理之後目前也是
重新讓它的均線糾結整理之後
翻揚往上
所以看起來
今天早盤也一度有攻擊的企圖
不過剛好這個地方有一個空方缺口
所以今天留了一个上影线
那就看明天或是说下个星期
五人机整个族群
是不是还能够凝聚市场资金
好 因为刚刚讲到的
像立山亥也算是多题材了
所以这个条例通过
我们就观察领头羊 雷虎 汉翔
能不能拉出一波比较长的涨势
这边非常谢谢微良
好 微良帮我们统整
因为这是反弹后第二次
我们攻上了4万6千点
两次这样反弹上来
其实领头羊有一些巧巧的不一样
我们率先选择两次都带头冲的
濒临城下即将要创高的话
这一些将士们肯定还是领头羊
所以今天率先讲的当然就是宰版
宰版刚刚讲了
原来南电跟新兴是可以配对交易的
未来可能景硕也要加入了
所以未来会帮我们画一张新的图
三家来配对交易
而会带动的是高阶同伯
也教了大家
搞不好不是观察投信
而是要观察那一只聪明的大户
有没有退场
另外无人机条例通过之后
当然后续还有很多戏目
我们需要讨论的
不过如果看到像雷虎或像汉翔
他们的涨势是比较连贯的
那有一些新小旗的个股
也可以来做关注提供给您
广告回来
我们的维泰要上场了
因为领头羊虽然长得很漂亮
大家心里面有点怕怕
那维泰就要告诉你
黄金右下角就在苹果的新品发表会
即将展开
好 剛剛我們講到
光學概念這一波超級強
但是不只光通訊
竟然有蘋果的概念
蘋果大家不是不喜歡嗎
怎麼現在喜歡起來了
因為這次的新品發表會
非常不一樣
好 這邊要請教我們的
黃金右下角
趙華好
選古教練為他
因為前面兩個都在講
比較創高的嘛
交給你了
我們要剪便宜
蘋果的秀
其實以前大家都會覺得
會不會了無心意
什麼的
可是這一次可能會有遮接機
然後可能會有一個M6的晶片這些都會是整個半導體很重要的事情包括我們自己有半導體站右下的還有設備跟特化可以挖黑嗎OK 好9月份其實是這個電子股或科技股
非常精彩的一個月份
因為首先我們可以觀察到蘋果的發表會
預計在9月10號禮拜四的凌晨會登場
那麼這次邀請就像這樣子
有這個驚喜要線
然後呢而且主視覺有這個發光蘋果
發光蘋果
光通訊蘋果
有可能
這次這個Google新的手機
也是有一個發光的設計
發光
所以這一次的新機好像對它有發光
比較亮亮的感覺
好 那市場呢
盛銷層上
傳說會推出iPhone 18 Pro系列
還有折疊iPhone
折疊iPhone
這真的是千呼萬喚使出來
微胎的手機有點時間
好像沒有換的話
還沒有換
那你要換摺疊機了嗎
我其實有在想
我有在想
那我們就看看它接下來
它出來的那個
到底規格到底是如何
那除了蘋果之外呢
這個台灣之光
半導體產業
我們的國際半導體展
預計要在9月2號到9月4號
那麼這次的半導體展
聚焦在AI的先進封裝
Keywords
小晶片
新小期的小
矽光值
量值技術等六大技術版图
所以我才說在9月份
尤其是在9月份上半旬
基本上的電子族群
應該會相當相當的熱鬧
對 而且大家不要有
蘋果的消費性電子
因為它在晶片上面
還有包羅我們台電
2奈米這些事情
對 都很值得留意
對 謝謝趙華幫我開場
好 我們講到說這個折疊機
其實這個之前大概兩年之前
我們就看到有非常多的廠商
尤其是一些中國大陸的廠商
都已經提早做推出
那麼這次呢
據傳這個iPhone的Artra
也是要推出這個所謂的折疊機
那它這次推出折疊機呢
有幾個比較
我覺得比較重要的地方
第一個就是
它所搭載的A20晶片
就是要用到台積電的2奈米
2奈米的一個技術
那相機呢
有48MP的廣角跟超廣角而且它是要做什麼極薄的設計而且是沒有長焦那我們先來看一下就是在剛剛有提到就是蘋果終於千呼萬喚死出來
它折疊手機終於有可能
會在這一次要推出來
那外傳的這些
所謂蘋果折疊手機的供應鏈
還有非蘋果陣營的這個
折疊手機供應鏈
幫大家去做一個對照
首先像最近長很強的這個台虹
還有軟版這個軟性的CCL
軟版的部分
那它有出這個所謂的
蘋果也有出飛瓶
這張表格基本上
就在找這個所謂雙漆的
同時有在出蘋果的
也在出飛瓶的
他們好像不只雙漆
不是蘋果跟飛瓶
很多都切到AI供應鏈區
對啊 像漆紅 雙紅
那如果說把它
共產在一起
我們要找一個雙漆的
就是這張表格
那這些個股呢
基本上我們認為說
他們有一些
就剛剛趙華所提到的
如果說你有吃到
就是說手機以外
就是AI相關的營收的話
會比較好
例如說齊鴻
它在今年一到七月的
累積營收成長80.34%
而且股價創歷史新高了
對 OK 好
那其他像是雙鴻也創了
也加了83.28%
這些都是有跨出到
所謂AI相關的
但是接下來
因為我不需要講
AI相關的個股
有很多都已經漲一大半
對
創下新高了很多
所以反而現在市場上面
給我的感覺是什麼
就是有一些就是
之前比較沒有漲到的
現在開始慢慢慢慢的
會有一些資金
在這邊去做一個佈局
我懂了
因為剛剛我講說
兵臨城下了
將士要先衝對不對
但是我們要叫後面的人
是 你上
趕快跟進
對 叫後面的人上
好
那在這裡面特別看到就是說
玉金光的部分
可是這個是創高的
對 是零投樣
可是說它創高
但是如果說跟這個
所謂大立光相比
我覺得它的漲幅其實還好
是用這種比較法
對 而且剛剛在這個表格當中
我特別去篩選
就是大戶持股有增加的
因為其實如果你去看這個大立光
它大戶持股其實是往下減少的
那反而玉金光呢
它在這個波段
它的大戶持股是往上做增加
甚至投信也開始回頭站在買方
所以站在整個籌碼面的結構上
我認為它的後續的續航力
可能會比較好
OK
當然啦
不管是郁金光
或者是大力光
短信上面長多了
出現正乖率過大的時候
我都不建議大家
〔此段辨識失敗，約 40:00 起〕